As I mentioned earlier, for going from
the implementation to optimization, we once again
turn to the theoretical framework. And in
this case, we're going to use this Nuprl theorem
proving framework. The Nuprl theorem proving framework
is a vehicle by which you can make
some assertions and prove some theorems about
the equality of optimized and unoptimized code and
let me elaborate. First of all, you start
with this OCaml code, which is unoptimized and
there is a tool that converts this unoptimized
OCaml code to Nuprl Code. This is once
again an unoptimized version of the original OCaml
code, but it is a Nuprl code and
this Nuprl code is one which is at
the base of this theorem proving framework and
what we can do with this theorem proving framework is convert this Nuprl code to
optimized Nuprl code. And through a whole
series of optimization theorems that are in this
framework, we can actually show that the
optimized Nuprl code is equivalent to the unoptimized
Nuprl code. So we showed so far
as the operating system design experience is concerned,
we're going to treat this as magic. And if
you are interested in digging deeper, I welcome you
to do that. But for the purposes of this
lesson, we're not going to go into the theoretical
details of how this theorem proving framework does
its work of ensuring that the optimized Nuprl code
is the same as the unoptimized Nuprl code. Now,
once this step is completed, then there is another
tool that converts this optimized Nuprl code
back into the optimized OCaml code. Now,
we are ready to deploy this. So this is sort of the design cycle going
one full round, going from specification to
implementation, implementation to optimization and from optimization
back to deployable code, that we can then take and put it on the system.